To the session on cancer detection, interception across tumor
types, addressing modifiable risk factors for early
detection. And here you see a QR code that
you can scan for eventually asking questions
through the remote system.
I'm Adriana Albini from the National Cancer Institute of
Italy, and
I've been working for over 30 years on cancer
prevention, and
I had the privilege to be the founding
chair of the Cancer Prevention Working Group
that has started in 2021
after I was in the ACR board and has now 7,000
members, which I think is really very good for
our field.
And I'm going to give just a couple of minutes of introduction.
Our session has to deal
mostly with emerging strategies aiming, identifying, intervening
cancer development at early stages across multiple types, with
attention to modifiable risk factors and precancerous
oncogenic drivers, going into the way of more
proactive prevention
models. And the session
deals with, this is a slide that I
took from Phil Castle, had a session yesterday,
of the various stages of tumor progression.
What we can do from normal cells, where we can do
primary prevention, to the interception phase,
and then what is therapy and mitigation.
Of course, we want to work very early on, and this is
many attempts, and I was very pleased to see how much
attention is to early detection and interception at
this meeting.
So after this
mini introduction, I would like to let the
podium to the first lecturer, Margie Lee Clapper.
She is a professor, Samuel Hemming-Thall Endowed Chair in
Cancer Prevention, and Director of the Cancer Prevention Interception
Targeted Agent Discovery Program at Fox Chase Cancer Center
in Philadelphia. For more than 30 years, her basic research laboratory
has been focused on development of agents for the prevention of cancer.
Margie Clapper pioneered one of the first U.S.
basic research programs focused on cancer prevention, early detection
in high-risk populations. Her research focuses including
genetic susceptibility, hormonal influence, and preventive
agents, as well as early detection strategies.
So Margie, the podium is yours, and I'm just going
to start your presentation.
So thank you so much, Dr. Albini, and
thanks for the invitation. It's certainly a pleasure to be here and share our data
with you. It's quite the honor.
So I have nothing to disclose.
I wanted to look back and share with you the progress we've made in cancer
prevention over the last 100 years.
And in the 1930s, we began to understand that chemical carcinogenesis was a
two-stage process consisting of initiation as well as
promotion. And about 30 years later, Lea Wattenberg and several
other investigators realized that we could actually reverse this
process, and he coined the term chemoprophylaxis.
We then moved into a very exciting era of chemoprevention and
immunoprevention. I joined the field in the early '90s, and at that point,
we were starting some very informative clinical trials,
chemoprevention trials, which really paved the way for future
direction in the field.
And then in 2011, Dr. Elizabeth Blackburn introduced
the term cancer interception, and she stressed that this was an
active process as compared to passive smoking cessation,
et cetera.
She equated it interestingly to intercepting a pass during a
football game, and in this case, keeping that
precancerous lesion in a sort of quiescent
state and not allowing it to move into an advanced
tumor. So of course, the topic of our discussion today.
Now with next-gen sequencing, we've come to understand that this is a very complex
area, in terms of the formation of this precancerous
lesion. A number of changes are occurring,
intricate changes, and these are not only in the epithelial cells, but
also in the supportive stroma, as well as in the immune
compartment. There are many investigators that are
trying to delineate these events.
As you can imagine, it's quite a difficult task,
but in part, this is being done through the generation of the Precancer
Atlas. So this is an initiative from the NCI that was part of the
Moonshot initiative, and it's leading to the formation of a
catalog of precancerous alterations for a number of
solid tumors.
And we're learning a lot from this multi-omics approach, looking at this at
different molecular levels.
So now we are sort of bombarded with a lot of
data, a lot of big data, and the question is,
which of these changes will be the most promising target for early
interception?
So I think these have to be the earliest identifiable alteration to get the
biggest benefit.
They should control a hub of downstream oncogenic
signaling.
Of course, they have to be exploitable, either with immune modulation or with
small molecules. And to achieve specificity, we need to make
sure that they are overexpressed in the tumor, as compared to the
normal tissue.So the greatest
need for these interceptive agents exists in those that are highest risk
for cancer, including those that inherit a
predisposition gene, and this has been our focus at Fox
Chase. This is about 10% of all the tumors that form.
And on the right-hand side, this table summarizes the most prevalent
syndromes, and it's estimated there may be as many as 50 syndromes
that are cancer-predisposing. I've listed the genes that are
mutated, and you can see that they confer increased risk for a
variety of different tumor types.
Now, in general, the estimated lifetime risk for these
individuals is 75% or more, and it can
actually reach close to 100%.
According to the Knudson two-hit hypothesis, those
individuals who inherit a germline mutation in a tumor
suppressor only need one additional hit to result in
complete loss of tumor suppressor function.
So we have a unique opportunity here.
We have an opportunity to intervene in the heterozygous state very
early in the carcinogenesis process, and I think importantly,
in individuals who are otherwise healthy and asymptomatic.
And we're hoping that the data that we gleaned from
these populations will be readily applicable to sporadic
cancer as well.
So I think the greatest advancements in this area have been in the
area of immunoprevention, and I'm sure you've already heard about this during this
meeting. We're very enthusiastic about results that recently came
out
in this
cancer paper,
on the NUSTRO9 vaccine, which I will get to shortly.
But this is focusing on the high-risk population
with Lynch syndrome. These individuals inherit a mutation in
the mismatch repair genes, one of the four genes.
This is the most prevalent, being an incidence of about one in 300
in terms of cancer syndromes, and it's conferring a risk for a variety of
cancers as well.
In these individuals, in cells that inherit a
mismatch repair deficiency, there is slippage of the DNA
polymerase. We get the generation of insertions
and deletions,
and the accumulation of mutations over time.
And if it occurs in the coding region, we get the
generation of frameshift peptides, which then promote tumorigenesis.
These frameshift peptides are not only specific to these
mutated cells, but they are also highly immunogenic.
And the hypothesis was that they could be used for vaccine development.
So this concept was tested initially by Matthias Klooer, who is now at the
University of Heidelberg,
in a Phase 1/2a trial. And in this case, he used three
frameshift peptides. He
vaccinated the Lynch carriers who had advanced stage colorectal
cancer and found that this vaccine was
well-tolerated, and more importantly, induced a robust immune
response.
So fast-forward, there are many initiatives in this area to try and develop
vaccines for these particular populations.
But as I mentioned, we are extremely excited about this most recent paper
in "Nature Medicine," came out this year, showing the
results from the first cohort who received this
NU209 neoantigen vaccine. These are
209 frameshift peptides that were specific for
tumors from individuals with Lynch syndrome, and they were
used to develop the vaccine. In this case, these
individuals had not had a cancer in the last six months.
They were vaccinated initially and then got a booster eight weeks later.
They were followed over a one-year period with colonoscopies at baseline,
as well as at the end of this one-year
period.
The data look extremely promising.
In the left-hand panel, they have used ELISpot
analyses looking at interferon gamma and see a very
robust immune response in those individuals
post-vaccine as compared to baseline.
And importantly, they find that this response is durable.
So 85% of those individuals had a positive immune
response after the one-year duration.
In a separate study, they looked to see how prevalent these
frameshift peptides were across pre-cancers and cancers and
found that of 115 frameshifts that they looked at,
82% of the samples included these
frameshift peptides, which suggests broad
applicability and very exciting application in
the future.
So I mentioned we are now dealing with a lot of data that's coming
out of omics platforms, and now the challenge is to figure out
which of these targets are most promising. And it was the vision of Dr.
Shizuko Sei at the Division of Cancer Prevention,
NCI, to capture this and use it to
fuel the drug development pipeline by creating the Cancer Prevention
Interception Targeted Agent Discovery program.
This was enthusiastically endorsed by NCI as well as many of
us in the field. And the goal is to develop molecularly and
immunologically targeted agents for the early interception of cancer
in high-risk populations, including those with heritable syndromes.
This started about four years ago with three founding centers, which included
Fox Chase Cancer Center, Weill Cornell Medicine, as well as Baylor
College of Medicine. And over the last four years, it's grown into
14 participating centers, including a data coordinating
center.And we are very excited to be part of this initiative.
So what I'd like to do today is to share with you some of the interesting studies
that are going on and some of the preliminary data that is being
generated.
So the first is a study that comes from investigators at Weill Cornell
Medicine. This is Dr. Vivek Mittal's laboratory, and the studies
were done in collaboration with his postdoc, Yongfeng Li.
In this case, they are trying to intercept premalignant lung nodules,
those
lesions that show up on CT scans. These are very
early lesions. They're called ground-glass opacities because they
present as a hazy area on the scan, which can then
increase in density,
and become, over time, a full-blown
adenocarcinoma.
Now, these lesions are due normally to inflammation or viral
infection, and these hazy areas are indicative
of the thickening of the interstitial wall or
collapse of the alveoli.
And about 30% of these lesions that are seen as non-solid
will go on to develop into invasive adenocarcinomas
over a four-year period.
So the
Mittal laboratory has done whole exome sequencing.
They've looked at over 200 of these lesions, and they
found that even in the non-solid case, about
25% of them are carrying mutant EGFR.
This was quite surprising. And about 40% of the
non-solid had mutations in KRAS.
They looked at the subtype mutations and found the most prevalent for EGFR was
the L858R, and for KRAS, the G12C.
And their goal has been to try and develop vaccines against each of these
mutated proteins.
What I'll share with you today is the efforts for an EGFR
vaccine.
They're using the lipo nanoparticle platform, the mRNA
platform, and the Moderna formulation, and they've modified this
slightly by incorporating pseudouridine to increase
stability. As you can see on the right-hand side, this vaccine is of
very high quality, and they've achieved an encapsulation
efficiency of over 90%.
Fast-forward after a lot of analyses, they've gone on to look at in vivo
efficacy, and, in this case, they have taken
cells that are mutated for the L858R
EGFR protein, and they've injected those cells into the tail vein of
mice. They've then randomized their mice to receive either the
vaccine or an empty lipo nanoparticle
vaccine. And after a prime on day five, they have
then done boosters at one-week
intervals. And the data generated from this is extremely
promising. They are seeing a robust antigen-specific
response increase in CD8 T cells, and I think more
importantly, they're seeing a dramatic reduction in tumor
formation in the vaccine group as compared to the control.
So more work to be done, but we are very excited about these preliminary data.
They show great promise and feasibility of being able to target
mutant EGFR. So the next steps are to look at the mechanisms that are
underlying this anti-tumor efficacy and then to further
optimize the vaccine.
This was quite an aggressive model, so what they need to do now, and are pursuing,
is to look in models that are less
aggressive, as well as making sure that these models are
relevant to humans.
So the next example comes from my laboratory, where we're trying to target
mutant p53 in the context of Li-Fraumeni syndrome.
Again, a heritable syndrome where these individuals inherit a mutation
in the tumor suppressor p53.
This is a bit more rare than what you see for Lynch
syndrome, but we think this is probably an underestimation of one in 5,000
individuals. Again, a spectrum of tumors that
these individuals are
predisposed to, and in females, the incidence of
cancer can be over 90%.
And 50% of these tumors arise before age 40, so there's
a great need, as you can see, to develop an interceptive therapy
for this particular population.
Now, interestingly, the germline mutations in p53 are very similar
to what you would find that are acquired in solid tumors.
The majority of them are in the DNA binding domain, which is from codon
100 to 300, and there's two different types of
mutations, those that disrupt the DNA binding
domain and the binding of p53 to the DNA, and
these are shown in blue. These are called contact mutations, and then there are
structural mutations, which are the majority shown here in red,
and they lead to unfolding of the protein or a decrease
in thermal stability.
Now, as you probably know,
mutant p53 has been a target for drug
development for decades, and there's probably 80
compounds that have been synthesized to date that have been
exploited to try and target this protein.
So why is it so challenging? It's very difficult, as you can imagine, to
reactivate a tumor suppressor as compared to inhibit an
oncogenic protein. In this case, mutation of p53
can lead to loss of function or gain of function.
In addition, the mutant protein is highly unstable,
so when we try to synthesize it and use it for in vitro analyses, it becomes
very challenging, and it's estimated there's over 2,000
different types of p53 mutations.
So what have we learned to date? We've learned that some of these compounds that
have been synthesized have off-target effects.There's been
some success recently with an agent called rosatapopt, and this was
developed by PMV Pharmaceuticals to target the
Y220C mutation, which is about 1.8% of
all p53 mutations. So it stresses that specificity
may be important because they are seeing a response during
preliminary clinical trials. However, they're seeing resistance, so that's
something that we need to keep in mind going forward.
So,
as I mentioned, we're trying to develop this reactivator in the context of
Li-Fraumeni syndrome. We're interested in developing an agent that can be
administered orally and ideally reverse more than one type of
p53 mutation, in particular, the hotspot mutations.
This is a study that started in the laboratory
of John Carren Nicholas at Fox Chase, where he did computational
analyses, and he identified a cryptic pocket in
p53. He then went on to screen over nine million
compounds for their ability to interact with this pocket and ended up
with some candidate in silico hits.
Unfortunately, at this point, Dr.
Carren Nicholas decided to go to industry,
and I inherited the project about 18 months ago.
So I want to tell you the progress we've made over that time.
We immediately set up an operational procedure in the laboratory,
and with the help of a very talented medicinal chemist, Dr.
Broderick, we were able to design compounds and
then send them to a CRO for synthesis.
They then came back to my laboratory for functional analyses, as well as
profiling for pharmacokinetic and metabolic
properties. This was then used to reinform our
design to enhance structure activity relationships, and we've done
this for about 400 compounds, again in the last 18
months.
This led to some candidate leads that we then took into in vivo
efficacy testing, and ultimately, we hope they will enter lead
optimization.
So,
in the interest of time, I'll go right to the punchline, and that
is that we have identified an agent which we call REM-491.
We've used two types of in vitro assays to screen
this particular agent for its ability to reactivate p53.
And the one is the classic RTQ-PCR analysis of downstream
targets of p53 signaling. We've looked at many, but we
find that Nox and Puma are our best reporters of
activity. And as you can see here, we see induction of
both of these downstream targets in the
p53 mutated cells. So Cal-33 are tongue
carcinoma cells that carry the R175H mutation.
And you can see we get nice induction of Nox and Puma in that cell line,
but not in those that are wild type p53 or lacking p53, thus
showing specificity.
Our second assay is mitochondrial outer membrane
permeabilization, which serves as a culmination of
pro-apoptotic activity.
And in the first set of
bars here, this is again the Cal-33 cell line with the
R175H in a homozygous state. We see dramatic
induction of the MOMP activity,
with an EC50 of about 40 nanomolar.
Now, if we're interested in using this compound in Li-Fraumeni syndrome, in the
end, we need to think about the heterozygous state.
So in this case, we looked at R273 in heterozygous
copy, and we find that the EC50 here is even much
lower than 40 nanomolar, seeing a very robust
response in these cells. And in both cases,
the EC50 here is very compatible with ultimate
translation into a clinical setting.
So we were very delighted.
What's even more important is that as we begin to look at other cell lines and
other types of p53 mutations, we find that this compound is
able to reactivate p53 across the board, suggesting that it
might be very broad-based in its specificity.
In each case, an EC50 that's about 50 or 40
nanomolar, and my crude estimation based on reports
in the literature is that we're able to reactivate about 25%
to 30% of p53 mutations.
In terms of the pharmacokinetic profile,
if you give a single dose to a mouse and look at plasma
levels after that, you see that the plasma levels are elevated
above the estimated EC50 for in vivo for about
20 hours. So this suggests that once-daily dosing will be
appropriate. We've also tried to establish the maximum tolerated dose.
We've not achieved it yet. We know it's over 400 milligrams per kilogram body
weight, and we've seen no toxicity or any type of
adverse effects with respect to blood biochemistry.
So my last slide is to show you that we're able to actually get anti-tumor
activity using REM-491 in vivo. So in this
case, we took breast carcinoma cells bearing the R175H.
We injected into mice, and then
randomized them to receive either their vehicle, which was PEG 400,
or REM-491. And the drug was administered
over a 17-day period, and at the end, we looked for toxicity as
well as an impact on tumor growth.
Again, in this study, as before, we saw no evidence of
adverse effects. As you can see, the body weight in the control group was very
similar to that observed in the treated.
We monitored tumor growth by caliper measurements through the old-fashioned way.
We also did luciferase imaging and weighed the tumors
at the end of the study. And in all
instances, we saw a significant reduction in the size of
those tumors in the treated group as compared to the
control.So this was only the second in vivo experiment we've done.
We have much more work to do, but we think this is very
promising.
So our current efforts are to improve the potency of this agent, and
we're spending a lot of time trying to determine that indeed
REM-491 is binding to mutated
p53. This is extremely important to show target engagement.
We're doing this in the next couple of weeks with X-ray
crystallization, and we're also using computational approaches
using Boltz2 and AlphaFold 3,
to further confirm target engagement.
So I hope I've convinced you that there's a lot of promise now,
with a lot of
new targets coming out of these omics platforms that can be used
as
strategies for intercepting pre-cancer to cancer transition.
There's a critical unmet need, I can't stress this enough, for individuals who have
hereditary cancer syndromes, and we think that valuable insight will be gained
from these individuals that can then inform other strategies for early
interception.
There is
great promise in using vaccines in the area of
immuno-prevention, focusing on tumor-associated
antigens as neoantigens. This is already in clinical trial, and I
think this is going to be revolutionizing the field as we go forward.
There's a lot of value in the in silico modeling, and I think one of our
successes relies on using these new computational
platforms to look at structure activity relationships and how we
can then go on and tweak these agents and make them more potent.
And finally, I hope I've convinced you that the field of cancer
interception is better poised now than ever to impact this
devastating disease.
So with that, I'd like to thank those individuals who contributed to this
research, not only those in my lab, but those in the CAPiT
Network. We're very thankful for the
NCI, for the funding, in particular, for the CAPiT project, and to Fox
Chase, who has also supported this initiative.
We're interested in expanding our cancer interception team, so if anybody
would like to join us, I'd be delighted to hear from you. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Dr Clapper, for your presentation.
And
for interest of time,
we thought to do the discussion at the end
all together so we can all sit here and discuss and answer
questions.
So I'm very glad to introduce our next speaker,
which is also Dr Suzette Delaloge, a medical
oncologist and researcher at Gustave Roussy
in Paris, France, specializing in breast cancer and precision
cancer prevention. She's the director of the Interception Personalized
Cancer Prevention Program at Gustave Roussy.
She coordinates major European initiatives and had
roles in ESMO, ASCO, and international research networks.
She has prestigious French and
international honors for contribution to oncology research.
So together with
Professor Clapper, I'm very honored to have you as speaker in this
session, please.
Thank you. Thank you very much for the very nice introduction.
So we will move a bit, and
discuss more how to operate this
precision prevention that we really wish to hear a lot about.
Can you hear me properly?
These are my disclosures.
Okay, so what are the challenges and what is the
vision? So very rapidly, because you've heard a lot about this precision
prevention or personalized prevention, precision being a part of it
during this meeting. The model, if we want to
operate it, is that assessing the
individual risk at a given time allows for the implementation
of appropriate interventions for people who are identified at higher risk
of cancer. And it's also of interest to identify people who would be
at low risk of cancer. We will mostly
discuss today higher risk, of course.
So in identification of a situation with increased risk
several years before the event will lead to propose very
targeted, better interventions with what we have today and
with what we will have soon, hopefully, in terms of early detection,
screening, and also risk reduction and prevention.
The idea would be to decrease the incidence of cancer, but also the
incidence of bad cancer. So personalized interception is
really a mix of risk assessment, early detection, and risk reduction
all together, and avoiding the fragmentation
between them, between risk assessment on one side, detection
and risk reduction, is really something critical.
And, a very important aspect is that we need to build that at
a public health level, and that's really critical.
So of course, primal prevention is public health.
Personalized prevention will be a part of the prevention that will first
be at a public health level. So we need to know how to
deliver this prevention at public health level, but also will feed the
primal prevention field of course. That's very interesting.
So personalized prevention uses the same exposome analysis,
the understanding of cancer biology, but we use more
personal factors, biomarkers, intrinsic factors, to
be able to drive the prevention for one single individual.
So how do we build personalized cancer prevention?
First of all, I think it's very important.
First rule is identify citizen needs and wishes, and not
just ours, not just, of course, the epidemiology is there, the costs are
there, but what do the citizens want?
And we've tried to build something that is really based also on the
citizens' needs and wishes, the people.
And then, of course, we need to build what we've seen today and during this
meeting. New risk assessment means early detection
biomarkers and tools, risk reduction strategies.
But also beyond that, there is a lot we need
towards implementing. So digital tools,
artificial intelligence tools, and biomarkersValidation
strategies at the public health levels, implementation frameworks,
guidelines, we need guidelines,
and developing the proper care pathways. That's a big question.
What are the care pathways for personalized prevention?
Who is in charge, et cetera? And at the end, support individuals
and society towards change. That's really something.
So what we identify is that there are some checkpoints here very early,
and it's really important, and there's a very big French program that is
currently being launched that is transversal not only to oncology, and
its transversality is quite important in other fields
but oncology, beside oncology, but also it's transversal,
with a crosstalk between the biomarker development, even the
basic science, and the implementation,
the interventional research, et cetera.
And what we identified is that the early preparation and accompanying of
new prevention strategies is critical.
First of all, if we want to afford for it,
so the early health economic modeling of intervention is really critical, but
also the acceptability, the social-psychological frameworks, the
preparedness, et cetera, so that we don't build things that will not be
used in the long term. And we'll see during this presentation
that we have many such examples. So very
rapidly, what is the state of the art currently?
What do we have in terms of risk assessment and stratification for
this personalized prevention? So well, breast cancer is a
very good example. There are other ones, but I think breast cancer has been a bit
leading the way in terms of general population.
Risk assessment and stratification must be, of course, accurate as much as
possible, meaningful for the people and the physicians and
the HCPs, and actionable. And currently, we have
a major way of identifying and stratifying breast cancer risk,
which is based on classical scores,
using exposures, family history, et cetera, plus timely biomarkers that
are mostly breast density nowadays, and SNP scores,
given the best models we have. And it took 25 years to
come here with models that are internationally validated
and, well, still a bit fragile, but.
And besides that, a lot is ongoing, and developments are very
rapidly
arriving. And we've seen a very nice talk by Regina Barzilay two days ago
in terms of AI, artificial intelligence assessment of
images, and this is very true for breast.
And apparently, what it looks like, some AI tools might be
able to do at least as good as the classical
predictors we have. And it's exactly the same for lung cancer.
We classically have the PLCO model, and there are some very interesting
image-based AI models that are arriving.
So we might be able to better stratify and
more easily stratify. So that was rapid.
Now, what levels of evidence for this personalized precision prevention
we have in clinics now? And of course, germline genetics
have opened a path and led the way very clearly.
So the initial precision interventions, like mentioned by the
previous speakers, have been developed in carriers
for BRCA, Lynch syndrome, et cetera, and especially for
BRCA carriers that have impact on incidence and some of them the
mortality. The level of evidence that we have are not that high because
it never happened that a randomized control study could be
conducted, but we have good levels, and it's really something that is implemented
in terms of MRI, early detection for breast
cancer, and risk reduction using
surgery, especially.
So well, breast cancer has been a pioneer as well in terms
of population-based stratification, the
tools that we have seen before in terms of risk assessment.
So where are we in terms of risk-based breast cancer screening?
Because this is the first place this stratification has been to, and
I've worked a lot on that. So it's already in place for
specific populations, as we mentioned, carriers, et cetera.
MRI for dense breast, two positive randomized trials, but unfortunately,
the feasibility is very poor, and that's a big problem.
They're, again, developing something that at the end is not affordable, not
feasible because it's too expensive, and the access is difficult for MRI.
That's a bit critical. So the risk identification, there we
are, and the general population level risk-based screening strategies
almost there at a level
1A evidence, not yet there. And we had the
results of the first randomized trial, the US trial wisdom,
a few months ago. It was a non-inferiority trial that compared a
stratified strategy versus standard screening.
The primary endpoint was incidence of Stage 2B breast cancer, but
also
the advent of false positives. It was positive only
on this primary endpoint, Stage
2B, and it's a non-inferiority trial, so as you see here.
So it's a first step. It was a bit underpowered, but a very
important first step. So in Europe, we have launched this trial
many years ago. It's the MIPEPS trials that compares in women 40 to
70 a randomized comparison
between standard screening during four years versus risk-based
screening. If your risk is assessed to be low, you get your next mammogram
in four years. If the risk is higher than average, you get a yearly mammogram or
even an MRI, but not all the population will get MRI, of course.
The primary endpoint is the incidence of Stage 2 and higher breast cancer.
And it's very interesting that we built that at the population level, and we
inserted this in
existing programs of organized screening in each country, six
countries, four years of inclusion, and the primary endpoint will be
available in 2027. So it's really been, hopefully, a big step
towards this risk stratification.
So what did we learn
about MIPEPS?So far. So first of all, it's interesting to see that
the short-term delivery of a PEARS score was very feasible.
Median turnaround time was seven weeks.
It was all academic
for 28,000 samples, so that's very feasible.
Probably less feasible than having an AI reading the
mammogram, of course, but it's not bad.
In terms of risk categories, quite meaningful.
We had
low-risk category, 36% of the population.
The mean age was 54 to 55,
and we have 33% of the population that is identified at high risk.
The high risk is quite conservative, it's
1.67% invasive breast cancer risk at five
years. And it's a very low amount that is at very high risk,
1.37. By age group, it's very different, so
it allows to stratify, of course, differently according to age.
We recently compared
the MIPEPS stratification versus the same stratification
UK Biobank, and indeed it looks the same.
So it's something at the population level that is reproducible.
We know that it's not exactly the same at the individual level, of course.
Well, we looked at how women were interested,
not really in risk-based screening, but in entering the trial.
So it's not exactly the same. It's a mix of both.
In MIPEPS, we have an over-representation of educated women, and
you know that it's true for any clinical trial.
So we have a 50% of the population
with a high educational level, and it's only 13%
with very low education level, and 2.4% materially
deprived, which is quite standard in Europe.
So that's always an issue. It's an issue with the trial, but we need to
make sure that it will not be an issue with the risk-based screening in the
future. Comprehension was very good.
The women at baseline really comprehended very well what it was about,
so that was very reassuring. And sorry for the typo.
We looked at the sociodemographic characteristic that impacted the
acceptance to participate in a trial that was in Spain.
And indeed, higher education level and higher
income is really linked to participation in the trial.
It is unclear whether it's just a trial or it's risk-based screening
itself. But
that's very important to know for the future implementation.
Very important as well, healthcare professionals' acceptability,
and especially in terms of risk communication.
So we had almost 800 healthcare professional involved in the
trial in the different countries.
Some of them very trained, some of them we trained with the trial, but not so much
trained. The majority was rather comfortable with risk
announcement, but a minority is very comfortable, especially
for low risk categories. Some of them did not like it, especially
radiologists for some reason. So what is clear is that
education and training is needed.
But the big question is: Who are the right HCPs to deliver that
kind of personalized prevention, or person prevention?
It's really unclear to us. So we had this
mixed method study in France recently, because in France, the
official physicians or healthcare professionals in charge of
prevention are GPs. So we did a mixed method study among
GPs. And while GPs really thought that it was their
duty to do cancer prevention, there were very few levels that we could
identify, mostly cognitive, not really emotional, and many
barriers. You know about that. Limited engagement, lack of time,
absence of reward, competitive activities, et cetera.
And they really knew little about personalized prevention approaches.
So there again, we need really training or identifying the right people to
deliver this care. So what are the current strategies and tools for
personalized prevention of cancer,
and risk reduction especially? What tools do we have at our disposal?
We have lifetime modifications that potentially could be very powerful, but
they require major political efforts and dedicated healthcare
organizations. Local treatments, that's for carriers,
very high risk. And drugs, vaccine, we've seen that this is
really a very interesting field. So if we look at the uptake
rate so far,
as a function of the magnitude of the expected risk benefit, it's
very variable. So the best uptake is for HPV
vaccine and salpingo-oophorectomy for carriers.
For mastectomy, it's a lot less. Unfortunately, tobacco
cessation, alcohol cessation, which have a very good
impact on risk reduction, have not a very good uptake.
And some others that represent a lot of people in the population
have both not a huge magnitude of expected benefit,
but it's still there, and an uptake rate that is not really good.
So we need to work on interventions that would have
a very
important expected benefit, but also very good
uptake.
With the ESMO prevention committee, we looked at
in 92 randomized trials that have tested drug-based cancer
prevention so far. It's only 92 in whole cancer
history. 50 of them were positive, but you know that the
implementation was very rare at the end.
It's only HPV vaccines and some endocrine
drugs that have been implemented.
And we looked at the predictors of success or failures of these
trials. And it is very interesting to see that
the trials that were sponsored for pharma companies had five
times more odds to success.
And it was very reduced for non-specific drugs, and
with a lower pre-trial evidence, you had one third of the odds
to have success. So pre-trial evidence is very
important.Another aspect of prevention is the
acceptability, the desirability of the drug prevention.
And we have recently published this French trial, LIBER,
that proposed a randomized study.
It was letrozole versus placebo for carriers.
And unfortunately, we had only an 18% trial
acceptance among carriers, and the five-year adherence was quite
low, 75%. And it ended up in an underpowered
study with no
observed effect on risk reduction.
So how can we overcome implementation barriers?
What are the challenges? Many challenges.
Delivering risk assessment at public health level, justice, equity,
affordability, a desired intervention, unification
between risk assessment, detection, and prevention, as I said.
With HCPs, guidelines, training, education,
convincing the patients and the society, and
organizing the anticipation and the
agility that is needed to implement the new drugs,
the new tools that are arriving. In France, we have launched this
program five years ago.
It's a pilot program. We call it interception program.
It's a mixed community hospital, digital program that leads
to the identification of high-risk individuals in the
community by HCPs, one-stop shops of
personalized prevention, and then a coordinated follow-up
in the community. And the digital part is very
important here. So we have pathways for people at
high risk of breast, pancreatic, lung, liver, colorectal cancer,
genetic syndromes, et cetera.
The objectives of the one-stop shop are very broad, and it's very
theory driven. And we've worked at and we've created this pathway with
patients, users. So it's activating levers, breaking
down the barriers, putting in place a personalized prevention program that is
a shared decision program, digital training, et cetera.
So we have large workshops. I don't have too much time to describe
in details. Nutrition and physical activity workshops
are always very important. Specialized consultations,
a lot of questionnaires, a lot of digital aspects, nurse navigator,
one day in a specialized expert center.
So the national rollout is here. We have seven centers open.
Many other are joining us.
This digital tool is both an app for the patients and a digital
platform for the healthcare professionals.
So the crosstalk is very important.
And of course, it's a health data warehouse, and we can implement clinical
trials directly in it.
Two small questions because we are trying to always be very
participative and know what people want,
and how to operate. This question, recent study,
a big question is, are lay people able to reliably fill risk
factors questionnaires? That's a big one if we want the physicians not to
do it because they don't have time, et cetera.
So in this study, we used 59 volunteers at a supermarket on a
Saturday morning to filling an online questionnaire on their telephone,
and they filled it again with a physician just afterwards.
The concordance is only 90.6%, so it's not perfect at
all. And especially for women, even if they have the report just
before them, finding and identifying their breast mammography
density, forget about it. It's very difficult.
Well, you're not surprised, I'm sure.
And certain items of family history are hardly
comprehended by people.
Age, sex, education level did not predict for concordance.
That's quite interesting as well.
Here we go. We also recently asked people about what are their
wishes regarding our digital platform.
So it's people who are already in the digital platform. What do they want?
Do they want chatbots to help them on their nutrition programs?
Do they want more reminders, et cetera?
Do they want interaction, more education, et cetera?
We had
184 respondents for this survey, and it's
interesting to see that there are different clusters. No surprise here again.
Selective users, moderate engagers, and people who are very
engaged, 64% of the population. High demanders, they want everything.
And interestingly,
among these clusters, age, sex, and education level did not predict for
the digital wishes profiles. So very rapidly, what is the clinical
impact of this program so far?
We are on the verge of publishing the main results on
cancers, but what we have in intermediate endpoints is very interesting.
An improvement of the WCRF score by one point
out of seven in 41% of the participants.
Very high adherence to screening and
very high increase of awareness.
So in conclusion, a lot is ongoing worldwide to build personalized
prevention, of course. Moving from limited indications to a broad
strategy that is offered to the whole population really requires
large-scale prospective demonstration, but also
preparedness.
Again, it must be developed at the public health level.
We must unify risk assessment, early detection, and risk reduction
strategies.
Yeah, as you saw, many implementations, challenges remains, and we have
solutions that we can work on. Many solutions.
A close collaboration between research area is critical very
early in the development of any biomarker, any drug, et cetera.
And the research must be participative and consider patients' wealth
and vision. Thank you. It takes not a village, but a city to
do all this. Thank you to all my collaborators.
We didn't speak a lot about biomarkers here.
And well, the advertising for the Cancer Prevention Research
Conference in Atlanta. Thank you so much.
Thank you, Dr. de la Loge for a very exciting
presentation. I've been hoping to realize similar
projects also in our institution, so
both speakers are invited to
come to us.
And,
so we're going to have the discussion at the end of the session.
So we are going to sit here and discuss.
And I'm going to go over a few of the things
that we have been seeing with some further thoughts of
reflections on early detection to
multi-cancer testing,
shifting cancer towards proactive prevention and interception.
Unfortunately, I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So starting talking about the easiest
thing or the most traditional thing to do early
detection,
screening programs. And so despite progress, current screening
programs cover only a limited number of cancer types
like breast, cervical, colorectal, lung, and I put prostate in a different
color because still is
debated.
So we think that at least for those tumors, we are okay,
but there are some problems already with the classic
screening,
organ specific focus, so individual organs limiting
overall view, limited coverage, only a restricted
number of cancer, and delayed detection, because
also the screening sometimes doesn't get early enough.
Now, there is another thing that might sound surprising, and
this is from
ASCO data of a few months ago, that the
adherence, for instance, in the US, and you see also in other
countries like mine in Italy, is not so high, in
particular here for uninsured people.
So that even for breast, which is a very wide
known, is 70%, colon lower, lung is very
low.
And that means that there are cancer discovered late
stages,
like 31%, 50%, 59%. So
also with the
routine screening that we have implemented, that we have things to
do. Then another interesting stuff that I know for Italy, probably it's
for other countries, that there is some sort of zip code effect.
So the country is not equally
involved in screening. And for instance, in Italy, northern Italy,
we have adherence to this is a mammography screening
of 60%, but we go as low as
30% in the southern part. Same is
for instance, for colorectal screening, which is lower also in Italy,
but it's very low in certain areas.
So definitely there is something that has to do with the health
organization in various areas, and probably it's going to be
very similar also in the United States.
So where do we work
to go beyond the screening that I showed some data?
So as you heard from the previous speakers,
we have to work possibly on normal,
healthy tissue before things start.
And
working with high-risk populations is a way to find new
biomarkers. But in an ideal world, we would like to be
able to also intercept cancer in
apparently non-risk or low-risk
populations. All this area is an area for interception,
and then we have to go to therapy and mitigation.
This is for instance, a scheme on how long it takes
before developing a full cancer, from my friend
Ed Giovannucci.
And, so
we can work now in this
area, but it would be very good to intercept even the
initiation because we know it's quite obvious to say that if
we detect cancer early, then the
survival is
much better for many different cancers.
So we have to shift intervention before the disease fully manifests.
We have to find biological signals to do the risk
stratification and define a proactive approach to block
cancer prevention.
Obviously, lifestyle is a very important
field because
many cancers are due to, for instance, smoke.
That's one of the major carcinogenic factors.
And it's not only lung cancer, but various others, for instance, urinary,
bladder, everywhere the carcinogens go.
Also, there is more and more interest, and there is a contemporary
session also on obesity to excess body weight.
We have a larger risk of
uterine and gallbladder, esophageal,
liver,
kidney cancer with being overweight and obese.
So that's another area of intervention.
As you heard from
Dr. Klotz, interception started with Elizabeth Blackburn
in 2011 and was the idea that when a cancer
start doing
something bad to our organs, we can stop it.
I was among the first people using that,
comparing cancer prevention interception just to have an idea what
you can do before, like do not smoke or quit smoking, avoid
overweight, or change dietary habits, and
treat inflammation, and several of these
interceptive things. So this is a
recent paper that we did for cancer prevention research,
which is combining various early detection methods to
have a better way to intercept. And this is
also a summary to,Avoid
carcinogens, quit alcohol consumption,
increase physical activity, and getting dietary
supplements. And also, for instance, repurposed drugs.
There is a lot of GLP-1 antagonists, but
older times, we were also working with metformin.
But the interception with lifestyle, as you've seen also in
the slides from Professor de la Loge,
is not so easy. There is not so much compliance.
Somehow it's easier to sell drugs.
We have guidance for what food to use,
and particularly in
Italy, there is a lot of fruit,
vegetables, and integral carbohydrates
and less consumption of meat. Here we also put a little glass
of wine, but we know that alcohol is bad at any level.
So you should come to Italy for doing this interception, because
Mediterranean diet wins every year the best diet in the world.
And this is US News, it's not from our own journalist.
Now, Americans reverted the food pyramid recently, and
the stack went up here. And
so sometimes, choosing a diet
has different opinions, I guess. Although epidemiology
goes in favor of fibers and vegetables.
So we still have to work on this.
Physical activity is my personal interest since I do sport.
And
we covered all possible physical health and exercise
benefits in a review with European Journal of Cancer
Prevention. And it's really amazing all the things that you can do,
from decreasing stress and anxiety to
improve cardiovascular diseases,
muscle strength, and obviously prevent cancer.
This through modulation of inflammation.
I heard a wonderful talk here also talking about exosomes
from physical activity that can be curative.
So we're on a study on using physical
activity together with neoadjuvant
chemotherapy in Milan. And it was very
interesting. There is a strong decrease of many
inflammatory biomarkers, so that now, our
studies and others, particularly colon cancer, show that you can
sort of prescribe physical activity as a real drug
or a therapy. And this was the design of the study, which is called
neo-runner. And obviously it's difficult to dose
physical activity. But this is a challenge that
we have, and also finding biomarkers.
So I like very much the hub that de la Loge is
developing. I want to try to do something similar.
So here we see the people with the
training and non-training. There is a regulation of
cytokines.
We also have a lot of interest in this meeting, going back to
carcinogenesis and the mechanism of cancer, and how we can
find the targets in the various exposures,
particularly pollution, for instance,
and also
other mutagens.
This recent
interest, for instance, in this field for many groups.
Also, I heard wonderful talks by Charlie Swanton
on the fact that we have maybe a mutational
event, but that not all carcinogens are mutagens,
and that many things just are promoting carcinogenesis
after an initial event, and one of those is, for instance, the
inflammation. So we can target, for instance, inflammatory
cytokines like IL-1 beta to see if we can
prevent the promotion of a carcinogenic
field after a mutation. So I thought, "Well, I've
seen these things before." And I went back looking at the studies that we
had done 25 years ago. This is a mutation research
paper that I published in 2001, and I
thought, I'm going to go back for some of those suggestions.
In 25 years, we've been moving slow, to say.
And we already had, for instance, the black box of
exposure, biomarkers of exposure, biological effective
dose, and early biological damage with primary prevention,
secondary, and then rehabilitation and tertiary.
And here, this is this long, long time where we can try to do
something. And this was a large number of
possible inhibitors that we proposed
so many years ago. So, sort of a
work for a weekend to see if there's something that
still can be re-proposed. So
the idea is to do a next-generation screening based
on the fact that the tumors release biological material in the
bloodstream very early on, and we know that cells
start moving from initial tumors, even very small,
early.
Searching for multiple signals like blood tests for signals
of multiple types of cancer. And some
sort of do a pre-screening, because then we're going to have to
do, let's say, a more classic screening to identify
alteration to do further investigations.
And liquid biopsy is something that now is almost routine for
many studies.
Because in the blood sample, which is
definitely a less burden for a person to do
mammography or a colonoscopy,
or a similar test. With a simple
vial of blood, one can study circulating DNA,
cells, inflammatory cells, proteins, circulating tumor cells, and
exosomes. As I say, as there was also an award to David
Liden for his work on exosomes.
So circulating tumor cells have been around for a while.
ctDNA with various way to studies.
Proteins and biomarkers and exosomes.
So with the liquid biopsy, also cell-free DNA, we can look at
many different things like sequence
alterationTranslocation, amplification,
deletions, fragment size,
and so many alterations can be studied
with
new kind of test.
And with the liquid biopsy and circulating DNA, we can
monitor disease all along the way.
So with cancer detection, early diagnosis, molecular profiling,
MRD,
monitor response, and also eventual clonal
evolution. So this is a very powerful tool.
For instance, our institute has developed many studies of liquid
biopsy in colorectal cancer. This is work
by Chardiello.
And here is early colorectal cancer, for instance, for early
detection, optimization of treatment, treatment selection,
monitoring, and studying clonal evolution.
Because also the DNA molecules retain genetic,
epigenetic footprint of cancer of origin, that opens the way
to find the multi-cancer early detection.
This some sort of, let's say, historical turning
point by a cancer cell of the Charlie Swanton
group,
to compare several of this multi-cancer early
detection tests that we're going to see what are the criticism also
on this kind of assay. And also, a recent
presentation by our immediate past president,
Lilian Siu,
on circulating tumor DNA as a biomarker in early phase
clinical trials. So how to use the liquid biopsy also
for early phases,
phase one and earlier, and to follow the trial.
This is
our summary of many of these things
from early detection combination, let's say,
where we can study all these risk
factors that you heard,
mutations, but not always mutations.
Demographics also like age, gender,
ethnicity,
personal
story, for instance, of infection, and then very important is also
the socioeconomic status.
There are also a lot of focus at this meeting
on the fact that
socioeconomic educational level can increase the
risk of cancer. And then, of course,
childbearing and lactation.
Lifestyle, metabolism, and nutrition are very
important. And there are other things that are
enablers like the chip changes, genome
instabilities,
telomeres changes, inflammation, of course,
hormones, exosomes, and microbiota.
All of these are a large number of very
important things. Now, it's a raising and blooming field, the one
on multi-cancer early detection test.
Don't just read them. There's just a large number of those that are
developed, and they work on different kind of
things from methylomics to fragmentomics.
And the thing about this is they need a
tremendous amount of
patients, because if you
analyze a non-risk population or a
population that is apparently healthy,
you're going to need to go on several thousand people to have an
idea or you can detect a cancer that
people don't know it's there.
So MCD test screening will target the healthy population.
Large scale studies are needed.
There's high specificity but variable sensitivity.
So they are still
in development.
And also, we still have to demonstrate the incidents of mortality
are achieved, and this is of course, a long process
because some of the cancer studied have a long time to
develop. So maybe
something easier, let's say, with pancreatic cancer, but more
challenging with breast.
So the MCD can extend the
prevention and screening methods,
improve diagnostic pathways, and obviously,
governance also has to be developed.
Another way, just one second on that,
for early detection is not only the liquid biopsy, but digital
pathology is helping a lot. This is also collaborative work of
our
institute in Milan with
Nicola Fusco in our pathology department, where you basically
can profile and even guess a genetic
alteration, germinal alterations in
cells that you get from a biopsy, from morphology,
from staining, from digitalizing.
And artificial intelligence is going to help.
So obviously, I cannot not mention because this
is a focus of many, many sessions, that artificial
intelligence is very useful in early cancer
diagnosis,
starting with defining risk models, as
Professor Dellalocia has shown us.
Also for analyzing images from digital
pathology,
for
choosing and seeing how strong the biomarker
analysis is, to analyze
possible
recurrenceAnd also
to see
how we can enroll people in
the studies on early diagnosis.
I'll just mention in closing
this talk,
some of the programs. This is, for instance, NCI Vanguard
studies, that, as I say, you need many people, so large
consortium, 25,000 total participants.
This is also from last year's ASCO.
I went on the website and they're still recruiting, and those
are nine geographic hubs. And the
Vanguard wants to assess willingness for
randomization,
adherence to testing, feasibility of protocols,
reliability of blood specimen, and also
compare two different
tests, multi-cancer detection tests, because we have many on the
market, and we had to see if we can assess
which is somehow more predictive.
So cancer risk, besides all we have seen,
is also related to economic, culture, education, social,
environmental, age, gender, and hereditary factors,
lifestyle, social community, living and working conditions,
general socioeconomic. This is more difficult than molecules to measure,
so this is one of our challenges. And therefore, we
need several stakeholders,
besides biologists and clinicians, engineers,
computational mathematicians for all our AI,
epidemiologists and population scientists, industry and
policymakers, and for prevention, there is always not enough
money. The entire research community, also the
patients' organizations.
So to conclude, oncological prevention enters an anticipatory
phase.
We had to implement screening programs because also those are not
perfect. Next-generation screening to integrate existing
programs. Evidence, governance, accessibility, and
sustainability are essential elements.
So early diagnosis is fundamental.
Liquid biopsy, digital pathology, and radiomics are the future of the
oncology screening, and they must be a priority of
healthcare. So we have also to go to our various
congresses to get investments for this.
Because we know that it is for better patient outcomes, and
also economically brings benefits to patients and economic
sustainability of healthcare systems.
So it should be definitely a priority.
I invite you all to join, although we have 7,000 members, which is not bad,
to the Cancer Prevention Working Group that was funded at the
end of 2021. This is my way to do
lifestyle intervention, doing fencing activity.
This is my sport that I do internationally, so as
a veteran. And this is a group of people that have
been helping doing my studies. Thank you very much
for your attention.
Okay, so we can go back to
the discussion time, and if you
have questions
for our speakers and generally to bring also your
opinion, mics are open. Please.
So I have a
question for Dr. Clapper.
Thank you very much. Excellent talk, and congratulations
on your P53 reactivator. The
pharmacodynamic or pharmacokinetics you showed looks really terrific.
Do you have ideas about pharmacodynamic
markers to bring along with that?
That's a great question, and we're not quite there yet.
So I think we have a lot more work to do to figure out mechanism.
We're hoping that will come from the crystallization studies as well as more
computational analyses. And of course, we have a lot more in
vivo work to do with different subtypes, different tumor types.
So absolutely, that is extremely important, but we're not quite
there yet.
Thank you.
To be continued.
Okay.
I have a lot of light that I just-
Thank you. Really, thank you to all of you for this
interest symposium. I just want to add a
reflection, let me say,
for all the things that you have shown us.
Can you speak in the microphone?
Okay.
Yeah.
For all the things that I heard, I think that really it
should be really important to build
big, huge biobanks of, for example,
blood, but from healthy people, let me say.
It seems something difficult, but really should be
a source of information
for intercept, but also for
get the
first part of the story when you cannot even
intercept the tumor. Just a reflection.
Yeah, I think we
all agree with that. A lot is expected from these
biobanks. A lot is already ongoing.
The resources we have are already enormous, but I think it's really
a reflex we must have. Each time we're launching any
program in prevention, we need to have these biobanks.
So I think all of us have biobanks, but we
need healthy people or high-risk people,
and we need cross talks between the biobanks.
So there are huge efforts ongoing in Europe to unify the
million genomes, et cetera, to unify different biobanks.
But
a lot is still needed regarding that. Agree.
Just I know one example that is the EPIC project,
in Europe. I know it.
The EPIC.
But, I mean, it is finished and no
progress
has been-
The EPIC was a huge-
Yeah, exactly
... collaboration between national cohorts and there was, well, there was some
material for EPICs, and a lot has been done with
that. But new efforts are ongoing in Europe.
I mean, the UK Biobank is also a very good example.
Some other national biobanks, and I think we have biobanks in
each country now.
To me, one of the issues is not to build the same thing in parallel
because, for instance, if you take lung cancer biomarkers, I think
1,000 teams or even several thousand teams are working on that,
biomarkers of risk assessment or early detection.
So unifying the forces and, well, making
sure that when you start something, you will have the validation cohort
and the federated possibilities is really critical.
Thank you.
Right microphone.
Thank you for the wonderful talks. This is Junseo from Korea.
I totally agree with that the prevention and interception
is the best treatment for the cancers.
However, we have to figure out who is the high-risk
population. So that means that the risk assessment
is the key for the prevention, I think.
And liquid biopsy will give a really high
odds ratio data for the risk assessment.
However, there are big two problems as we know,
the cost and the sensitivity, because we have to use for
the general population. I think the cost is quite important in this
area. However, we all know that it's more than $1,000
for a single assay.
And second, for this subclinical
cancer biology, we have to
do a really high sensitive, ultra-sensitive assay,
to detect the kind of
mutation alterations.
So I think there are still two big problems for the risk
assessment. So I want to
listen your opinion that we haven't solved yet in this
field.
I think you can both answer on the same.
Oh, yeah. Biomarkers for risk assessments, I think there are big, big questions
that we have to solve. A big question that is arising, of course, is
should we do germline genetic testing for the whole populations
everywhere, and at what age, et cetera, with what technology?
And it's quite costly right now. With the new
platforms that are arriving,
in our country, the crude cost is two hundreds to have a
whole genome sequencing,
that will give you a germline assessment.
So it's really much, and you would do that once in your life.
So I think that would be affordable.
It's still a huge amount of money if you want to do it at a
nation level. And,
well, in terms of germline genetics, it's also PRS testing
that is potentially interesting.
I mean, not just for one cancer or one disease, you would do that for
all types of disease, all types of chronic diseases.
So for PRS testing, same thing, either you would do it on your
whole genome, that would be really feasible tomorrow, pan
PRS to assessment, or you could have your
specific chip that is not so expensive.
Well, the chip itself is not that much.
It's more a matter of having the right persons to
analyze it and then the right persons to deliver
this assessment to the people. So that's really the part of
these genetic aspects.
But it's only one aspect. I mean, genetic testing is
just a small aspect of risk assessment.
So I think what we really hardly need now is a better
assessment of risk. So I'm really interested in artificial intelligence and
images.
For some diseases, pancreas, lung, breast,
it looks really interesting, but I strongly believe that some
biomarkers will be very helpful as well.
And what we need to meet, the first thing I would put in
first, first demand I would have, is a biomarker that
would be actionable, meaning people would see their biomarker
improve,
once they are doing some
risk reduction actions. We need our cholesterol.
This would be really very helpful for motivating people, et cetera.
Because, well, whatever the amazing technologies we
have,
it's very hard for people to identify this
hidden risk that we are speaking about and to motivate themselves to do
something, either change their lifestyle or take a drug or use the
vaccination, et cetera. So I see a lot
arriving, but we
really need that kind of biomarker that will also follow
the disease. And in terms of cost, the crude
cost should not be that high, depending on the technology.
I think the cost of the technologies, proteomics is
decreasing a lot. ctDNA is decreasing a lot.
So I think that could be affordable in five years from now, yeah.
Thank you.
Long reply. Sorry.
One more question.
Hi, this is Ada from Wiley. So I have two questions.
The first question is for Dr. Klaper.
Among all the vaccines that you have developed, how many of
them have doable effects? Meaning that you could vaccinate for once,
and then, it is a lifetime effect. And then a related
question would be, because we all know that the tumors evolve,
then would the
neoantigen or the antigen disappear, and then the vaccine
will no longer work? And what is the benefit of
being vaccinated in this case?
That's a very good question.
If I can repeat, the question is about vaccines, if they're
long-lasting,
vaccination against cancer and these biomarkers that
you have, and also if their tumor evolves and there are new
neoantigens, if you have to do, for instance, a novel vaccine to
some other epitopes.
So just a long-term vaccination strategy.
So I think the data that's come out of the NUS09 vaccine trial
is very encouraging. So it suggests that over a one-year
period, that vaccination is durable.
So I don't think we know how often we would need to do that based on the data we
have, but it's very encouraging to suggest that indeed,
there is a durable response.
And then, with respect to increasing
mutations over time, obviously that, I think, is going to happen.
There's some
recent data from using the
rizatriptan compound, and what they've found is during resistance, they
actually get more P53 mutations. So I think as these
tumors evolve, of course, we get additional mutations.
These therapeutic agents that we are developing, I think will not only be
effective very early, in terms of early interception, but I
think they will also be very useful for solid tumors as well.
Thank you.
One more question.
Hey, my name is Maren Wischer, and I have
a couple of comments.
One of them is to
the question, are we going to get a cholesterol for cancer?
I'm the director of a biochemical lab, and I think one of the
challenges is going to be that you have
so few cancer cells initially, so whatever
they put out is going to be diluted so much that
unless it's DNA, we're not going to be able to pick it up.
All of us believes in thyroid hormone, but the American
Thyroid Association actually counsels against
measuring free T3 because it's present in the
plasma in picomolar concentration.
That's so low, you cannot pick it up precisely with
immunoassays.
So it's going to be a challenge.
And I have a comment to telomere length as a biomarker.
I spent five very hard years of my life measuring
telomere lengths in 47,000 people,
and they were followed for 20 years with complete follow-up,
and we saw no association between telomere lengths and cancer risk
prospectively. So I think a lot of what has been reported has
been
confounded by age.
And then I have an actual question, which is,
what are your thoughts on exercise as a
measure to prevent cancer? Because one of the things that is a little
confusing to me is that people who
are paralyzed
do not have increased risk of cancer.
So how can that be, except from bladder cancer because of
recurrent UTIs?
Have anybody
thought about that? Because I think that is strange.
I can answer some of these
points.
It's true that
maybe in certain cases, there is not so much
evidence, but the increased sedentarity,
which is also accompanied by weight and changes in
metabolism,
it is a risk factor.
It was very difficult to do studies, and now there are some
good results that show that there is an improvement,
particularly,
in what has to do, like secondary prevention, after
somebody has already a cancer. And obviously, there has to
be some sort of supervised, also exercise, because in
case there is already
oncology problem, maybe there is sarcopenia or a risk of
cachexia, and that's also going to be helped by
physical exercise and
muscle health. So we think that it's
incoming and, also in
combination. What we see in the trials that we run at our institute
are a combination of maybe chemopreventive or therapeutic
agent and dietary intervention and physical activity,
and also, for instance,
start
experimenting intermittent fasting and
many things that have been shown to improve, let's say,
the general health of the
individual.
For the cholesterol, I think
Professor Delaloye can tell you something.
Sorry, I can't remember the question about cholesterol.
What was it again?
No, it's just because I have the same wish to find the cholesterol
for cancer and have-
Oh, yeah. Okay.
Have had it for 25 years, but I think-
Yeah, I heard that. Okay.
It's too-
No, we don't have a single biomarker that would be relevant, I agree, but
it doesn't mean we should give up. And it's
probably not, of course, so simple that we would have a single
biomarkers for all cancer type or situations, et cetera.
It's not a CRP or whatever. But,
I think a lot is ongoing right now that might very
rapidly be used, at least for specific cancer or risk
situations. I mean, for lung cancer, it's arriving, for pancreatic
cancer.Breast cancer, I'm not so sure, but it might
happen. Something that is actionable and meaningful is really very, very
important.
It can be genomic or non-genomic. I think both have
chances to make it.
But I think it's going to take another few years before we have
something strong and before we are launching the
prospective trials. And it would be so useful
to have surrogate endpoints before that kind of
surrogate endpoint before starting our trials as well.
So that's a big question where you see when developing,
especially risk reduction interventions, it's so
difficult when you take incidents or even mortality as the
primary endpoints, almost takes years, and if it's a
reduced population, it's very, very, very difficult.
That's an issue that you might have for many
vaccines and Lynch syndrome, et cetera.
So of course, having intermediate surrogate
biomarkers would be also critical in this.
So to me, it's a very, very, very high priority, and I hope you
won't give up working on that.
Yeah. I think
two other things just to close in the session. We have about three minutes.
Certainly, biobanking is very important also to have
something when you find a new biomarker to go back and see if these people have
developed cancer or not in the time.
So it's some sort of generous project.
But now, for instance, in many sessions, we have data from the Nurses'
Health program or Epicords that have been
started
many, many years ago, and you can go back and also
try to have questionnaires that go together with the
biological material to see the lifestyle and whatever.
So I liked your
supermarket questionnaires. Certain things probably are more difficult to answer.
For instance, for the question of physical activity, is I don't think that
people really know how much physical activity they do, walking,
gymnastic,
running, going to the gym, or just doing the steps
or walking the dog. So it's something more
difficult to quantify than taking 81 milligrams of
aspirin every day. So this is a
few things. And also what I always struggle is
the cardiologists have some sort of easy risk cards
because they have the
cholesterol and glycemia and various other things and
also lifestyle. But I think we
should all work on a model to have a better
selection of what is not germline or genetic risk,
but really
more general somatic
risk.
I have a
last question
to
Margie about the RAM 491, because I
think this is a really paradigm shift that one can target
the oncogene suppressors.
So what are the perspectives to have it as a
registered drug that can
really help various diseases with the P53
mutations?
So we are very excited about the data we have already.
Obviously, we have a lot more work to do.
But I do think if we continue to see this
activity against a broad spectrum of
P53 mutations, we're hoping to move quite
quickly. We're not a big shop, and in 18 months
we've gone from basically a structure on paper to something in
the mouse that has anti-tumor activity.
So we're working very hard to get this into an early
phase clinical trial and into populations who will benefit as
quickly as possible.
But we have some additional hurdles to go over.
I think the biggest is target engagement.
So we really need to show that our drug is actually binding to
mutant P53, and that's the focus of our efforts in the
next couple of months.
Thank you very much. Thank you for the wonderful speakers, for
people staying here, listening, asking questions, and I hope we
start all new collaborations in this increasing field.
Thank you, Adriana.